me kevin smith have you been looking for
all my old podcasts the ones i started
recording back in 2007 well guess what i
found them they're all hiding
in that kevin smith club all that shit's
not exclusive enough we got three more
shows that are
only going to be going on at that kevin
smith club the return
of plus one the marital podcast that i
did with jennifer for years wake and
bake
with kev that's right a video show where
every morning whatever i'm doing while
i'm smoking man you're gonna hang out
with me and then of course the exclusive
kev
cast man that's the podcast of me just
by myself
or i just kind of do my own self therapy
while you listen
see all the video you've never seen
including exclusive movies and
live shows you want some swag that kevin
smith club is making pins
and miniature versions of my old scripts
if you want to be involved in the least
exclusive
most inclusive club on the net join that
kevin smith club
now's your chance to club kevin smith
[Music]
hey oh welcome to fat man beyond i'm
kevin smith
i am mark bernardin hey
ho when i watch that ad for that kevin
smith club
i see a young man at the beginning of
the pandemic
that's when we shot that
he didn't know what was going to happen
for the next year mark
it was going to be rosy all [ __ ]
sunny days give us a couple weeks we'll
be back out and about
he was like look man like you know but
i'm sure
by i don't know like uh
may we'll be out of this he was wrong
he was [ __ ] wrong maybe not this may
yeah yeah [ __ ] him uh
welcome back kids it's a special friday
show
good friday show but every day we do
this show is [ __ ] good as far as i'm
concerned
we don't need some church to tell us
it's a good friday
it's a good friday when fat man beyond
is happening
we're doing it uh now as opposed to
saturday or sunday because this is
easter weekend
and some cats you know got [ __ ] to do
and whatnot
here we are gathering together on a
friday night
mere hours after the debut of
falcon and the winter soldier of episode
three
which naturally we'll be deep diving on
we'll talk about uh invincible
and i'll show off uh an invincible
kit that they sent me and whatnot and i
watched it it was awesome we could talk
about that
um we get and then mark's got news for
us and i know some [ __ ] has been
happening
ooh you know some things you've been
you've been here into the to the to the
pavement
i kept my horn to the ground man and i
heard some [ __ ] couldn't miss it it was
on
uh social media i believe this morning
one of the bigger stories but we'll get
to that
when we get to the news no guests this
week uh kids but that's okay me and mark
are used to doing the show without
guests and
providing the same entertainment value
as people who make your favorite shows
um as we conjecture
what we're thinking as opposed to
actually get it
directly from their mouths um
before we do anything though
housekeeping is an order man
somebody gotta help us keep the lights
on here at our separate houses
um somebody got paid jc for all this you
think he does other kind of
heart jc makes a [ __ ] small fortune
in the real world doing technological
[ __ ] jc pop in here bamf in here and
take your bona fides
tell them what you've been shooting man
i do
um all the digital production for all of
the
hollywood reporters uh award season
stuff
so uh like you know sound of metal
got a bunch of uh got a bunch of noms
and uh hollywood reporter has a a
special little
thing that you can uh
buy into i guess and they send out this
the they do a special movie screening of
sound of metal
and then afterwards you can do a q a
with
the stars and the maker people who made
the movie so i've been recording and
editing all the
q a content all the the hollywood
reporter roundtable stuff
um i did the billboard news
grammy pre-show i have 1.2 million
viewers on it which is pretty exciting
it's way more viewers than we get not
that much
why don't you tell them about our show
while you were there like drop
in some [ __ ] graphics with links that
lead them back
but like you gotta go see this show if
you think this is exciting
wait till sunday when fat man beyond
airs
then they show up on sunday and nothing
would be there because we're doing it on
friday
um it's a it's a a
sweet thing that jc makes the time uh to
do this show and and whatnot because
he's
he's out there [ __ ] working every
damn day and stuff
with famous people there was a uh a big
debate about whether we would do the
show
friday or saturday early because i was
supposed to
shoot an interview with doja cat in
malibu tonight that got cancelled
so we ended up on friday mark where's
your hat
you gotta wear something protective just
look out for all these dropped names
um i don't know who dogiacat is but
apparently i've heard that yeah
what uh what happened um
i told him i only had like an hour and a
half
in my day to get there because to drive
to malibu
they want it was 7 p.m to drive to
malibu to get there on friday by 7 pm
is is a two-hour drive and then there's
a two-hour drive home i said i can't do
this
and they came back and they were like
well we don't know
when dojo will be available so
can you just kind of be there all day no
so they just canceled it you
[ __ ] douched out on doja cat
well i think that the producers also
didn't want to sit there
all day waiting so
no doubt you could always pull the baby
card where you're like hey man i got a
baby at home
it was i was kind of like well and they
didn't have their budget was
minuscule so i was like i can i got 90
minutes for you
plus travel and they were like we need
you for seven hours i was like nah
i'm gonna do fat man instead i don't get
out of bed for less than 20 grand
um well look at that man jc is always
working on something so
it's nice that he uh comes here and does
this and whatnot but
we gotta [ __ ] pay him for his time
people's time is valuable and whatnot
what what i did all day what where i was
all day today was scum and villainy
getting set up for our opening this
upcoming week
and how we pay jc kids apparently is the
plugs the free flow
yeah that's that's the real value that's
where
you go getting the messaging right here
when uh
when is the grand opening again uh we're
doing a special ticketed event
on april 6th for
um our our fourth anniversary
even though it's kind of our third
anniversary because we our third year
got blipped out of existence by the snap
of kovid
uh so we're really only been around for
we've been around for four years
real world time but coveted time three
years uh so i guess it's our fourth
birthday party
um so we're doing a special ticketed
event and then we'll open up
uh later in the week for people to come
and hang out
again in a socially distanced manner
what uh if people want to go where can
they get tickets um
they can go to uh bit.ly
slash scum n villainy
which i just dropped in chat for
everybody still sounds complicated but
whatever
why not um uh you know what one of the
one of the one of the viewers
set it up last week so who am i done why
not just scum
scum for fun oh
that's already taken i'm 100
um all right man so people can go there
uh if they want to go there
and actually be in the in the space and
uh
you know april 15th everybody starts
they open up the
immunizations the vaccinations to
everybody out here
so i i've heard something today about
public performance spaces are
going back to like 50
or something like that they're starting
to reopen those so that means
it's going to be show time soon indeed
we
uh we just went to orange tier so we can
have 50
capacity at scum
but you have to abide by the social
distance rules
which makes it so that we can basically
stay at 25
because people have to be eight feet
apart and dividers and everything so
we're not
our space is so compact that
we're about the same but it's exciting
it means we're moving in the right
direction
truly better than being closed um well
that's awesome man
scum and villainy on the rise ladies and
gentlemen and we'll be doing the show
back there hopefully pretty soon too
yeah as we were just saying before when
we were like we'll be back
live somebody said too much tummy time
um that's right um what are we gonna do
about the [ __ ] gorgeous picture
though man you gonna give us two
separate cameras so we each have our own
singles
like i'm gonna yeah i'm gonna try we're
gonna i've been talking to andrew we're
gonna try to um
add a few cameras and broadcast in 4k
and do all sorts of fun stuff when we
get back
so nobody needs to see how [ __ ] old
we look
they're makeup before that's not going
to help this show although
ladies and gentlemen if you look uh
to the lower right you'll see a man
fully illuminated mark got himself a
brand new ring light is that what i hear
oh and it's a big one too it's the size
of a
hubcap man it's gorgeous
welcome to the to the 2021 my friend
yeah like i'll show you i'll show you
the one that i used to use
okay which it's this big
which means all it sort of did was like
whisper some light at me right but now i
got the big [ __ ] like
hey look at that [ __ ] look at that man
you're illuminated we could see you i
can see clearly now
that light it's on
[Music]
well done future baby i'll tell you
right now
lights aren't cheap kids as i was
getting that before before jc
insisted on [ __ ] selling scum and
villainy oh guarded you
yeah he jumped in there and he's like i
see an ad space
um ring lights are not cheap none of
this is cheap man it's cheap for you you
get to watch it at home for free and
stuff but
there are costs involved so of course
fat man beyond
has a sponsor as often as we can and as
many as we can we'll take them all
this week we got one sponsor who we love
who must love us because boy oh boy they
keep advertising right here on fat man
beyond so
somebody's getting hairy ladies and
gentlemen
uh they're they're the good folks at uh
keeps ladies and gentlemen keeps.com
let me send you there right now as we
have this chat with you
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man
because if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss that's what we're
about to talk about
you go to keeps.com fat man to receive
your first month of treatment
for free that's k-e-e-p-s dot com
fat man to get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man man you
know why two out of three men
will experience some form of hair loss
by the time they're 35.
i'm 50 and it's love is a battlefield up
here kids why do you think i wear funny
[ __ ] hats
it's not because i'm like uh colorful
like a like [ __ ]
carrot top or some such [ __ ] i got a bag
of props behind me although i do have
some cool [ __ ] to show off
um i wear the damn hat because i lost
the hair battle man
as i'm cresting toward the [ __ ] grave
i got like nine hairs [ __ ] left and
[ __ ] and i wish
keeps had existed back when i was a
young lad because i'd
i'd have done what they suggested with
their very name and keeps
all that hair and stuff like that more
than 50 million men in the u.s suffer
from male pattern baldness i'm one of
them i love my father and my grandfather
but [ __ ] them they ruined my head
i wish keeps had been my dad mr keeps
because i'd have a lion's mane full of
hair if that was the case man there are
only two fda approved medications
that can prevent hair loss kids keeps
offers both both
mark take over it you know i i too have
a little bit of a
follicly challenged dome going on and i
also wish that perhaps i had heard of
keeps
back when i could have done something
about it and if you are on the verge of
being able to do something about it
do something about it keeps offers a
simple stress-free
way to keep your hair and it's low-cost
man treatments start at ten dollars a
month
and keeps offers generic versions and it
comes in discreet packaging
and it offers proven results
what are you waiting for kids don't you
want to keep your hair
take it from two bald old [ __ ] who wish
that they had [ __ ] had something like
keeps back in the day for heaven's sakes
man
don't be follicly challenged don't be
married to a life of funny [ __ ] hats
go try your [ __ ] out man go try out
keeps.com go to
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man
you can get your first month of
treatment for free
ladies and gentlemen prevention is the
key treatments can take four to six
months to see results
so act fast right now go to keeps.com
k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash fat man do it
save your hair save your life i saved
the i gave you the final word
and the best you could come up with is
save your hair save your mind
save the cheerleader save the world i
was actually pretty good i was like [ __ ]
we should have led with that
save your life naked from us two broken
old man we wish we had saved our hair
oh god i tried springs from your head
i put it in a bowl and i had glue and i
couldn't make it [ __ ] work um all
right thank you to the good folks at
keeps
for sponsoring tonight's episode
we're gonna get into falcon and the
winter soldier but first
yes a little show and tell ladies and
gentlemen thank you folks who keep
sending us [ __ ]
i'm able to show [ __ ] off this is what i
got from the folks
at amazon original for
you can see my ring light right there um
for
invincible look at this big ass box
what the [ __ ] is in here put my name on
it
big old picture of invincible and
whatnot i i like
i appreciate these and i love that they
send them
but don't these people understand i'm
watching the show either way
[Music]
save your money i says um all right let
me pull over an apple box
everybody is looking at her
okay one more time before we open this
bad boy that's huge it is
well i mean amazon knows people who
deliver [ __ ] so they figure they can get
a good rate
i don't even thought of that all right
so we open up the box
the unboxing you don't get to see that
part but that's just me opening the box
jesus uh there is
uh invincible uh number one
i don't know if it's a reprint i'm
assuming
yes not a first edition and i'm just
giving away
first printings uh it looks like
animated series promo but i mean i i
don't know if it's brand new or not
that's a good question
if only we could ask somebody close to
the source that would be our good friend
robert kirkman um oh he has a letter
inside
says hi there i hope you like your box
of cool invincible stuff the animated
series
comes to prime video on march 26th and i
couldn't be more excited for you to
watch
um it's his second longest comic book
series guess what was number one
um super dinosaur
very nice note but nothing about the
contents uh this is a little
poster of sorts strength
flight recovery his powers
his powers right then
okay what do we got here this is a card
that says
now that you've had a chance to hone
your skills and load up your utility
belt you're ready to get out there and
do some good in the world
see we can all be heroes we partnered
with
give back box to provide you with an
easy way of recycling this box by
donating any unwanted items
to a good cause just visit give
box dot shop slash discount slash
invisible explore their charity partners
choose one that speaks to you
then fill the box with acceptable
donation items
which are listed on the site and used
the promotional code
invincible to cover shipping oh that's
smart so
this big-ass box you know you you can
you
go to the approved list and you fill it
and then they'll come pick it up and
you know it's full of donatable you
can't put like you use dildos and [ __ ]
like that
have an acceptable list and i'm sure
that wouldn't be considered acceptable
but that's a good idea
it's a very good idea i mean especially
because most of these things
are going to people from the press and
if you're on those kind of press lists
you get a thousand of those boxes a year
you know more [ __ ] than you can handle
and and it's the
it's the weirdest craziest thing to say
but it becomes a bit of a problem of
what do i do with all of this free stuff
and the fact that they've now realized
that and have given you a mechanism for
them donating it all and making it easy
to donate
that's really smart it is props
um all right what else is in here i've
got
a liquid iv
hydration multiplier electrolyte
drink mix one stick multiply
your hydration so it's you know powder
you stick in a drink
um astronaut gatorade then i've got
amazon halo band
what is that feels like a fitbit maybe
or some version of a fitness tracker
you're absolutely right labs body
composition activity
sleep tone of voice
so free
the rich get richer
um a sakara energy super bar
energy not sure if it's vegan we'll find
out
uh tectonic brand light roast coffee
ooh i'll shake you awake
notes cherry caramel chocolate
processed washed region ethiopia in
colombia
and then what's this what is this
oh heavens ferragon
mini the massage reinvented
that is a huge dildo i'm doing kidding
man i guess you can recycle the [ __ ]
vibrator
uh look at this and that looks like it
would do some pounding look at that it's
like pound
pound pound this ain't no vibrating
rabbit ladies
this is pound town right
[Laughter]
and then soothe some eye patches
oh that's nice um i don't quite get the
theme
of all of this stuff together i'm
imagining the theme is
um you were out the night before
fighting crime
and uh and it hurts and now you gotta go
about your life
and so here's the [ __ ] that'll make you
better and help you recover
from being bloodied by somebody close to
you
i gotta tell you naturally i want to
send the box back with things in it and
[ __ ] but
there's got to be like some invincible
mega fan out there that's like
gimme it i want the box like [ __ ] the
coffee just give me the box
um when we go back to i'm saving all my
[ __ ] when we go back to the
to the uh scum and villainy
cantina cause i don't know if you guys
heard this or not but
it's opening back up maybe we can get jc
to pop in and tell us about it
he's he's very rejected to talk about
the bar
um but you know i got a bunch of [ __ ] to
give away a lot of the freebie [ __ ] i
got so i'm gonna bring it to the bar and
people who come to those shows
you can walk away with an empty
invincible box which is you could walk
away with a full invincible box
you have one too you got one i got one
but i i have a feeling that there is
some [ __ ] that we've all gotten
uh over the last year or so that we are
happy to give away
a little bit i mean i'm happy to share
the wealth
let me share this wealth with my wife
hey just clean it up before you give it
away
my wife uh got her uh
shot second shot and she was
she's down for the count yeah that
happens
shot number two is a [ __ ] skull
smasher
um well thanks speaking of skull
smashing thanks to the good folks at
invincible
uh robert kirkman and friends for this
kid now let's talk about the [ __ ]
show
holy [ __ ]
i've watched the first three fantastic
um you know i i didn't read the book so
i didn't know
what what i was in for and or what i am
in for
the end of that first episode is uh is a
doozy
holy [ __ ] like and the way it's
structured in such a way
that you know it reaches an apex and
they give you a title card and you're
like oh right on
and you see the bar and you're like but
there's so much more time left
isn't the show over and then all of a
sudden it's like
oh no oh it's going on and then i
thought they were giving us a series of
shorts
like let's take a look into the lives of
their justice league what are they
called
oh i can't remember squadron supreme or
something like that
and then instead they did what they did
which
you know look we're about to spoil
invincible kids if you have not seen it
uh
or come back in like three minutes or
something
so here we're giving you five seconds
five four
three two one
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] man like
i know if i go out and google and and
read the comic i could probably
find out what's going on but i love not
knowing
because that ending [ __ ] blew me out
the water
like i was ver i texted kirkman after i
was done
and i was like i was about to text you
halfway through the show to tell you how
wonderful and warm
and charming you know and how like
just what a [ __ ] what a fuzzy blanket
of a show this is
and then you know the end happened
and you know i'm glad i waited you mad
[ __ ] genius
in the last few minutes of the episode
you know
uh what's uh oh is it omega man
it's like omni man omni man that's it
uh invincible is the kid hero the whole
show begins with
a world of superheroes and
their superman is called omni man
omniman is married in his secret
identity and he's
got a young son and that son you know
his
his superpowers are starting to manifest
and and he's also starting to show the
might of his father
the strength of flight of his father his
father is like a kryptonian from another
planet valtrium or something like that
so you know it tells this kind of warm
story of
a father preparing his son
for the life that he's known yeah and
secretly
the catch is so adorable where they're
literally throwing a baseball
the long way around the planet and then
catching it and then again
and again and if that was the show
beautiful
still on board i'm there for every
episode
but you know if you if you've
seen it you know [ __ ] yeah omniman
goes [ __ ] crazy kills the entire
[ __ ] justice league as
brutally as as possible in a cartoon i
had no idea we were in for that kind of
cartoon where it was like
look at this [ __ ] look at the blood flow
look at that
[ __ ] neck snap it was incredible an
incredible
ballet of [ __ ] comic book violence
that
goes beyond where most comic books have
ever gone
so at the end of that i was like you
have my attention and i watched two and
[ __ ] three
fantastic show yeah that is such a smart
storytelling move i mean it's it's not a
it's not a trope
um but it's a it's a tool which is
the audience now knows something that
will drastically affect the life of your
protagonist
who doesn't know it yet and so the
audience is on a secret
and you now inform every other episode
with
when is he going to learn this and so
every time he sits down for dinner with
his dad every time he has an innocent
conversation about his dad
anytime anybody talks about omniman in
that world and mark grayson is like
that's my dad
you know what's coming you just don't
know when it's gonna happen
and that is such a smart a smart
savvy way to invest the audience in
what's going on because it buys you
their attention that tension and
attention it rhymes they're almost the
same word
fancy that it is a beautiful show
as well in the third episode when uh
spoilers again uh omniman
travels back to the other planet through
the wormhole or whatever
the boom tube and it's just like you
know earth is not yours to conquer
and just [ __ ] lays waste to their
entire world and [ __ ]
um and like just blast through walls
holding their martian leader until all
that's left is like a [ __ ] skull
and he just you know crumbles it and
[ __ ] that whole sequence
was like something out of heavy metal
you know like it was goddamn
beautiful and like whole show's
beautiful but in sequences like that
it's so stylistic and you know because
they went to a completely different
planet
um fantastic cast across the boards
oh it is like the the thickest animation
cast i've seen in a long
time yeah yeah right up there with
masters of the universe i i dare say
indeed he bought a big piece cast
seth uh rogan came in did the alien guy
allen the alien
um really great stuff man how many
episodes is it do we know
um i don't recall he i think he might
have told us but i think we also forgot
it might be 10.
and now they're going into the drip mode
right we're like we'll never
three again yeah it's three three to
beat you
and then they got you week by week after
that and then they give us the boys
treatment after that
um i have loved the first three thought
it was absolutely fantastic
uh now look forward to watching it don't
know if i could get my wife into this
one but i'm gonna try
i think you might be able to though like
because i think the mother-son story
um is great you know and there is some
other son's story as well
and oscar nominee stephen young is
killing it as mark grayson
yeah and who is it jk uh jk simmons is
his dad
ak rowling the magic of jk rowling
[Laughter]
is there nothing she can't do um yes
jk simmons who like you know
did the character uh omni man have a
mustache in the comics as well
yeah it's almost like they built it for
him
he sounds wonderful um yeah and like jon
hamm doing like a side voice
yeah just like there's jason mansookis
over there and there's
oh hey jillian jacob's over there just
like everybody you've heard
it's like huh oh that's cool
yeah it's great if you're not watching
it kids get on it man it took me
two weeks to get around to it but i saw
people like in chat
um going like hey man talk about [ __ ]
invincible talk about invincible
and so this week i [ __ ] downed it and
was like holy [ __ ] and they're
thick as a dick man like [ __ ] each
one's almost an hour long
yeah that's that's a lot of money in
animation land
yeah man that's meaty but worth it worth
the trip they got that amazon money
they're they're [ __ ] sending out
vibrators they got that
um congratulations to robert we'll have
him back on the show
you know we were going to have him on
after it was over i don't know maybe we
get to halfway point and have him
jump back in for a little bit and [ __ ]
yeah he's always [ __ ] gold he's a
wonderful guest but
you know now we could be like holy [ __ ]
well i was i was like now we could suck
his dick over it
you actually did suck his dick over it a
little bit because you saw him before i
should yes i got in first you have a few
seconds
yeah and i was like give me that one
away
probably be smart for me to watch the
show when we have the guests on in the
future that's
don't don't do that it's the
freewheeling footloose fancy free
version
that i think that people respond to
truly um
so if you don't sleep on invincible kids
and you can't
it's particularly the last like [ __ ]
ten minutes of episode one
um it's uh special stuff uh kirk been
doing the lord's work yet again
uh amazon helping him do it and a cast
of like every famous person
ever uh involved so great great stuff go
check it out
um all right that takes care of
invincible yes
that brings us to the time i i didn't go
to chat for the invincible conversation
because i was afraid people would spoil
it
like because now like normally we
conjecture like you know on wandavision
and
falcon in the winter soldier we could
sit here and be like i wonder what's
going to happen and speculate
but with invincible like it's been
around for a minute right
yeah two weeks i think no no i mean as a
book
yeah the book is like 12 or 13 years old
so
so like they're probably following you
know the storyline
so there are spoilers if i want to know
what's gonna happen i could probably
find out
but i don't wanna because i kind of like
being like
at sea like what the [ __ ] is going on
man
um yeah i have to imagine that you know
at least
early on in the show they're gonna hew a
little bit to the comic book because
even kirkman said it like you know i
wrote this story i know how it goes
now there's going to be some innovation
incidents and turns you don't expect
along the way
but much like walking dead after a
fashion
did sort of follow the general tides of
the comic book like we
went to a prison we then went to terms
we went and we did these things
you meet negan like all that stuff did
happen but there were some
some sort of new inventions along the
way new characters that might not have
been in the original but
so yes if you want to know the big
movements of invincible they already
exist but i'm sure there's going to be
some new [ __ ]
the new friends we made along the way um
also uh i was just watching before i
came here
um the wework documentary on hulu
how is it pretty [ __ ] fascinating it
has
very little to do with our world here
and whatnot but if you're looking for a
good documentary about like
the cult of personality because that's
all it was dude was just a sale
like a really good salesman so good that
like people forgot that like
so wait your main business is you buy
buildings and then you
subdivide them and rent space out like
how's that going to save the world like
it was one of those like places where
they were like we're changing everything
and really they weren't changing
anything
as long as you're not going to tell me
that we work is also
like a deep sacrificial cult for the
elder gods
while i'm sitting in my we work office
you're like oh dude you should watch
this documentary they're going to kill
you in like 15 minutes
you just wait till the lights turn out
we're all done here you're gonna be
sitting in that office and you're just
gonna hear over a small speaker
don't watch that documentary
[Laughter]
like what what are you saying wework
don't watch that documentary
we have our offices and we work and i
still found the documentary [ __ ]
fascinating that guy's gone he's long
gone but
man oh man it's like you know
he wasn't like he was a wonderful
salesman he just didn't really have
anything to sell
but but oh my god could he whip people
into a frenzy
um you know i'd like to think that i
wouldn't
have bought it i would have been like
like one guy in the documentary is like
they're renting [ __ ] desks you know
you know because it's
grandiose talk about the future and
about like
changing like they created we work we
live
they were like creating kids school like
we educate or whatever
fun and you know at the end of the day
like they build themselves as a tech
company but there was really no
tech you know they're just a real estate
company there's renting
places out but apparently the valuation
between like what a building was worth
and what they said it was worth was
completely
different and most people know the big
story which is
like you know their 45 billion
valuation going down and down and down
but it was pretty interesting
documentary but anyway
yeah you know what i've been watching
before we get to [ __ ] winter soldier
there's a documentary series i want to
say it's history channel it could be
discovery channel
they're all the same channel at this
point called the food that made america
and uh the episode that i watched that i
found fascinating
was about the rise of pizza joints
in any place that wasn't like new york
and connecticut
specifically the rise of domino's pizza
and pizza hut
and you know they they eventually became
competitors but they were just these two
like small businesses that began in the
middle of america
and had the burden of introducing pizza
to a populist that had never heard of it
let alone tasted it
and you know the the thing that i found
so fascinating was the pizza hut guys
were like trying to figure out a way
with almost no money to make a thing
called pizza
and they didn't have any recipes so they
just sort of like
i hear it's dough and sauce and bread
and so they went into their [ __ ] like
kitchen lab and started making it up and
i found an italian to taste it
and it's like this isn't pizza i don't
know what the [ __ ] this is and they're
like it's okay
we're in montana nobody knows what pizza
tastes like
but you know what they'll like they'll
like this and then that began
this sort of empire of pizza hut and
then domino's
was trying to be a restaurant that did
everything they wanted to make like
sandwiches and subs and pizzas and
and burgers and fries but they couldn't
afford
a space big enough to serve everything
like listen we only have enough room in
this place for like the kitchen and
three tables
we can't possibly attempt to make a a
fortune this way
so they eventually said you know what
we're not having any people in here it's
delivery only
like there's no eating in here we'll
bring the pizza to you and then
they had too many [ __ ] things on the
menu like a greek diner and they
eventually like and there were two
brothers who are fighting over like
who's gonna be dominant one brother was
like well [ __ ] we're cutting the menu
it's only pizza the other girl's like
but what about the sandwiches jimmy
he's like you guys do what i tell you to
do it's a big [ __ ] like inner
turmoil sibling rivalry thing but it's
it's always worth remembering that
everything that's
giant began as like two dudes in a room
were like i got an idea is it a good
idea i don't know
like should we make good pizza does it
matter you're right it doesn't nobody
knows what good pizza tastes like
cool and then they make billion dollar
companies that ultimately fuel america
now you've got i'm going to watch that
for sure number one but number two
you're right pizza hut pizza isn't
really pizza
no never has been they never they never
attained
they never promised you quote unquote
good pizza
here's a thing that we're calling pizza
yeah it's it's not even like it's bad
it's just
everything is sicilian there everything
is like this high
yep like they don't just have guy get a
slice like you're
in a pizzeria it's always you know it's
it's
extra everything about it was always
extra and whatnot but i've never really
thought about that
the fact that like when you step back
from it you're like
well other than the fact that you might
get a round shape
you know it does have dough and sauce
and cheese involved but
it's not it's not technically what a
pizza is i hadn't
really thought about that i remember the
proliferation
of pizza huts like throughout the 70s as
a kid and whatnot
um we pizza hut was in
my world considered a luxury like you
only went there on special occasions
because we had like real pizzerias like
a touch of italy or something like that
where you get a real [ __ ] pizza
pie and stuff
so like i remember whenever i'd be like
can we go to pizza hut
like my dad would be like no we're
having another we're having
regular pizza tonight pizza hut was
considered special pizza
isn't that crazy and he was you know and
honestly pound for pound
he was right because [ __ ] the regular
pizza you got from pizzeria
you know thin good but thin [ __ ]
pizza hut pizza you could feed an army
for like a week on the on the [ __ ]
thickness of it and [ __ ] like
that so maybe my dad was like a quantity
not a quality buyer
and i remember you know being a kid and
you know especially in in public school
they would always talk about like the
food pyramid
and healthy diets and all that [ __ ] and
pizza was always
the best fast food you could eat because
ultimately most of it is fresh
if you're getting it from a dude who's
making it fresh cheese and fresh tomato
sauce and
the crust isn't that much it's not a ton
of carbs so like it was
quote unquote okay for you better than a
cheeseburger better than
you know whatever until you get to pizza
hut and the [ __ ] crust is this thing
it's
mostly starch everything else is kind of
synthetic
and it's yeah it's a thousand calories
for a [ __ ] slice of pizza
like but it tastes good oh it's all the
oil and the salt and the butter they put
in there and there's so much sugar in
the sauce you won't know any different
it's just
i'm sorry are you fasting did i [ __ ]
things this is hour
49 of my fat
so i'm like they do put oil in it don't
they
boy that sounds good keep talking
get mine as well
yes i'm gonna use it i'm gonna put it
right here this is like that scene
in [ __ ] midnight express man where
i'm gonna ask you to put them on the
glass and [ __ ] like that
talking about that food putting them on
the glass oh
kevin um man that all sounded [ __ ]
good as hell
for the first time in a long time i was
like i would eat pizza hut right now
that'd be amazing i would do that it's
not vegan but you know what
fair enough i got vegan pizzas and stuff
but they don't make them as [ __ ]
thick as a dick
and whatnot um it is it's kind of like
an all sicilian menu over there like i
remember
like at our pizzeria every once a year
or something my mom would be like we're
getting sicilian tonight
you know and that's the [ __ ] pizza
that's like deep dish just real [ __ ]
large and stuff
but even that was a special occasion
whatnot pizza hut turned pizza into a
special occasion
um but the most iconic thing about that
restaurant to me
and i'm sure it's long since changed i
haven't been there in a while
where the you know checkered uh
tablecloth covers or whatever the
plastic tablecloth colors and the
red plastic tumblers i hope they still
incorporate those in some way
and those like stained glass light
fixtures that would always hang over
every table that made you feel as if
you're in like a legit pub
somewhere yes like oh this is it feels
like we're in the middle of
italy look at this place this is the
glass it's like the sistine chapel of
pizza places
um welcome to food man beyond with me
and mark
where we talk about cuisine and [ __ ]
we'd like to be eating right now
yeah this is our fasting and the furious
podcast
yes but that made me so hungry right now
i'm sitting there going like
seven o'clock now my eating window
always closes at eight
so if i end the show right now
i have 56 minutes to order a pizza and
devour it before yes and we're done
goodbye everybody no questions hi
everybody
youtube.com
um all right we ain't done it we're just
getting started man [ __ ] all that food
food here's what you gotta remember
about food food is absolutely
my addiction thing you always have to
remember about food is it ain't going
nowhere
like all that like pizza hut they ain't
going nowhere
so you know in this moment i'm like [ __ ]
i need pizza hut
i don't i really don't i'm not even
hungry but
i can comfort myself by being like when
you are
hungry and when you do break your fast
and
now for and probably until the end of
time pizza hut will always be
like you and if it's not pizza hut you
just find a ridiculously large you know
piece of [ __ ] sicilian pie
and you're probably in the same
neighborhood to some degree always got
to remember
food ain't going nowhere when you give
something up like sugar
you know sugar's gonna be there when you
get back man they cracked the coat of
sugar a long time ago
it ain't going nowhere so pizza is not
going nowhere i could do without pizza
for a while
i i i look forward to the inevitable mad
max future
where there's some sad dude living
eating [ __ ] dust and dog food
um who's watching that loop over and
over and over again look
guys food ain't going nowhere yeah
buddies rolling around
like [ __ ] killing people
cannibalizing on the outback
food ain't going nowhere man it's always
going to be there for you
really orange hat man they refer to me
as the
the horned fool
you wanted to see the god of lies here
he is right now telling you the food is
going to be here forever
i suddenly am side by side with the q
anon
shaman for two white idiots with horns
in their heads
who didn't realize they were so so wrong
um okay yes never mind so so wrong
something so so right ladies and
gentlemen
is uh disney plus as a series right now
the three
episodes in falcon and the winter
soldier
uh episode three just dropped last night
and uh you know at midnight so early
this morning actually
and i have watched it uh twice did you
watch it more than once mark or just i
have not i watched it uh this afternoon
no this morning
um when i woke up knowing full well that
we were gonna get into it tonight like i
tend to let it wait till friday night
it's my friday night like slow down
like hey i'm gonna have this uh i don't
know maybe a bottle of wine
maybe a little a pair of teeth and get
into my comfy pants
i'll watch you some falcon winter
soldier and then just nod off into a
good good night but no i had to do this
morning
because friday belongs to fat man i tell
you
you made that [ __ ] aperitif sound
good i'm like
i got i'm writing a list where i'm like
when i break my fast pizza hut number
one
apparently number two then i needed a
pair of teeth
if i could combine the two a pizza hut
aperitif well [ __ ]
i need some pizza pork it was uh
it's a good episode episode three really
good
um it they didn't spend as much
on this episode as they spent on the
first two no gigantic
[ __ ] off action sequence that's why i
said to jen after we were done
and she was like well no sharon carter
kicked ass and i was like i didn't say
there were no fights
plenty of those but they didn't have one
gigantic
like look at this [ __ ] and i i kind of
narrowed it down to
the wings didn't pop out he didn't use
his wings once if he ain't using the
wings
the show is infinitely cheaper right
right then he's an episode of the
rockford files
this was i mean i wouldn't call it a
bottle episode but this is like a very
inexpensive episode i doubt that they
budget them per episode i think they
just budget
the whole and that's it but this week's
was you know it just didn't i
comparatively
couldn't have cost as much as the first
two by virtue of the fact that they
weren't fighting on top of moving trucks
or
swooping in and out of [ __ ]
helicopters and [ __ ] like that
right still it's not like it lacked for
any action whatsoever just didn't have
those giant action sequences and what it
lacked in that
it wisely made up for in other areas jc
join us bamf in here
i saw some you know some interactivity
on twitter did we ever get a
zemo watch we did we i got several this
was the one i was able to get into the
show though
all right let's see it let's see boom
you know what very straightforward
nothing wrong with that
[Laughter]
in my mind it was a little fancier very
graphic
package but whatever we'll take zemo
watch right there
um zemo watch uh began with episode one
and uh we saw no zemo in episode one
at the end of episode two we got a touch
of zemo
but in episode three mark
they went full zemo
full to the hilt balls deep
call the man his name
baron [ __ ] zemo when they said
at one point when they were like so what
you're rich all this time you've been
rich and he's like
i you know before [ __ ] scovie i i am
a baron
and you were like
because he's called himself zemo and
they've referred to him as zemo but
nobody's ever once said baron's emo
yes he literally said it in this episode
not only did he say well i am a baron
but then later on
i think it was uh falcon who was just
like baron zemo here
which delighted me no end and then
on top of it we got to see him first in
the coat
and i was like oh they're gonna make a
slow build they're gonna wait until
episode four to put on the mask
but they did not wait till episode four
to put on the mask
and the [ __ ] strapped on the
mask and went full
zemo in episode three so for those on
tight zemo watch as as i have been it
was an
orgy you can keep your big [ __ ] truck
uh fight sequences and your big
helicopters
you give me all that zemo and not only
did they give me zemo and a mask
they gave me zemo dancing out of
discotheque
the whitest dance you ever seen in your
life
and it was just pounded out i'm going to
pound it out get a pound
pound pound and i also love that he was
like
you know [ __ ] richie rich zemo who
could just fly everywhere
has his own uh [ __ ] jarvis or alfred
if you will
esnick or whatever the [ __ ] um and he's
just and he's helpful
like he's [ __ ] super helpful guy like
you know
they've got a common mission and as much
as like no more superheroes and [ __ ]
like that
so they're all getting along it's a
happy [ __ ] weird little brady punch
and then the final moments of the
episode
they upped the ante because they're like
hey man
not everyone is happy that [ __ ] baron
zemo
you know is in a discotheque [ __ ]
who would be mad about this of course
the people whose king
he [ __ ] killed and so one of the
what is that how do you say dora the
dora melaye or a melange
show up was it oh it wasn't
and the last time we saw her she was
fighting [ __ ] corvus glaive right
like in the lab
wasn't she the one who was like fighting
him um
trying to think yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i thought that
character died
you know cause like he was a pretty
tough customer but
uh alive and well and in an alleyway
in the middle of [ __ ] words just
dropping off uh
kamoyo beads all over the place it was
awesome once i saw that beat i was like
and what a perfect way at first i was
like oh my god they're bringing shuri in
but like what a perfect
story device to weave in which is just
like not so fast
baron zemo ain't such a great guy you
know we got [ __ ] debt with him
and this is gonna complicate the mission
even more um
fantastic that aspect of it um bringing
in sharon carter which you know we knew
from the trailers was happening
developing her as an as an art dealer
who has the real art like i thought it
was really scandalous that they were
like
that [ __ ] in the louvre that ain't real
real [ __ ]
something you've always heard on the
internet and whatnot um bringing back
agent
13 was that her name agent um and
letting her be this like off the grid
kind of carrie mathison [ __ ] went
rogue
um you know former shield agent whatnot
who's had to live by our wits
and showing the repercussions of marvel
adventures in the past what i love about
what they're doing with the blip
storyline
is like you know in avengers end game we
were like oh thank god they brought
everybody back
but the horrible repercussions they've
been dealing with
like ever since man like kind of like
look this ain't such a great thing or is
it such a great thing or look how it's
displaced the world and stuff
and they did something in this episode
as well that was kind of like
similar where i was like oh [ __ ] how
great to bring that thread back into oh
i think the wakanda thing where i was
like
how smart to just tell a story now of
like never mind
their mission [ __ ] justice
is demanded over here and
him being like the um what is he the
white wolf or whatever
bucky having spent time in wakanda
like it all just makes sense i didn't
see that coming like oddly enough
i didn't see the whole like he spent so
much time on wakanda
maybe wakanda comes into the storyline
but they're sparing no expense with
these [ __ ] shows
man like when they're they go to
madrapore
and like i don't know where they shot
that but hey
they didn't [ __ ] magic but b like
that [ __ ] like that beautiful bridge
shot
where they're across from high town and
they're about to walk into the city and
stuff like that
clearly a manufactured shot that exists
nowhere but the fact that they did
magic pour it all man is one step closer
to mutants like more way closer than
anything ever happened in one division
magipore for those that don't follow
that's a mutant [ __ ] stronghold been
in the comics for years and years and
years man so
the moment they said the name i was like
you know they get me so easy all they
have to do is reference some [ __ ] where
i'm like
holy [ __ ] so i thought for a second as
we watch this i'm like
is this where everyone thought we were
going to start seeing mutants pop up in
wanda vision i'm like
is this where we start [ __ ] catching
wind of mutants
if magipore is nothing if not mutant
paradise and stuff like that a lot of
stories take place a lot of x-men
stories take place
yeah wolverine spends a lot of time in
in majapur new mutants
is where we first met major poor it
comes out of that book
um so yeah it's it's claremont chris
claremont do it
i think he created he created magipor
yeah i think so
i think so um so yeah it is and whoever
this power broker is
you know part of me thinks the power
broker is also zemo and we're sort of
quote-unquote chasing our own tail
um because of course he's gonna
not be trying to get to the power broker
but if he's afraid of the power he's the
kaiser soze
of of this particular story that's good
i i was going with sharon carter i was
like sharon carter
is the [ __ ] uh is the power broker
but i like yours better that's good
um but yeah the fact that that if it's
not zemo
if that could be a mutant you know
whoever is calling the shots of magic
poor could be
you know [ __ ] mojo it could be long
shot it could be
it could be anybody it could be don't
start this [ __ ] this is that mephisto
[ __ ] i want to be everybody's like the
rabbit is mephisto the [ __ ]
the bug on the on the windshield that's
my vista
we don't know but that that'd be that'd
be [ __ ] dope
yeah it'd be great if this was the show
that introduces mephisto
it's like guys we were all over it there
saying oh it's like mephisto and the
winter mephisto
guys like it's all like you didn't see
me coming
[Laughter]
um man oh man uh what did you think of
the episode i
i was i'll be honest with you i was like
you know there's only a little
touch on the isaiah bradley storyline
and as much as they're
the one scientist the guy who recreated
the super soldier serum and
name checked uh name checked erskine as
well
um he referenced like oh we had blood
that we pulled you know from somebody
that was the only isaiah bit that they
touched on so we didn't go deeper into
uh isaiah bradley this week and stuff
but uh
so i was a little disappointed in that
because it was like oh after last week
i'm like all right
we're heading in that direction hardcore
but
they this one was pretty much like the
action adventure
hour you know crucial and also great for
like
you know i'm certainly it's not an exact
parallel but like [ __ ]
if we were telling a lethal weapon story
zemo is
you know [ __ ] the joe pesci of the
[ __ ] so
you have to let them bond as a team but
now we'll see
and zemo had like two or three chances
to get away
and doesn't you know comes back and
rallies with them and stuff like that so
i think there might be something to your
theory about him being the power broker
yeah like i dug this episode it's very
much a procedural right like here's
here's our clue trail we gotta talk to
this guy who will then lead us to this
person who will then lead us to this
person we gotta go undercover here you
gotta be the winter soldier again
which was kind of cool and like you
gotta be the smiling tiger which
sure i dig that um
it was very much like here's our miami
vice episode
of falcon and winter soldier um and to
that end like yeah no it's fun it was
small i
i did bump a little bit on the sharon
carter of it all
because it felt like that was a
character that wasn't sharing carter for
a long time
and then they were like hey but what if
it's just sharon carter it's like okay
where was she the last time you saw her
oh training to be an fbi agent
okay so now she's a criminal underworld
boss
who's like literally killing people
overseas
in a land without laws kind of a wall
and on her own
yeah i mean that's a big jump from fbi
trainee like young agent starling but
sure okay like it could have been a new
character we can make it sharon carter
um so like that kind of the drive-by
character explanation of that stuff
was like oh that's quick but sure i
suppose
yeah the how you got from here to there
it was yeah like uh
you know she was like ah i just gave it
all up and became very hand wavy like
things happen in the five years like
oh i liked though that she was like you
know after i got the shield back and
[ __ ] and after i [ __ ] got you your
wings but she was like i got
your wings so you could help him beat
him or something
um you know it it stands to reason that
like
other people got their [ __ ] cleaned up
she didn't get her [ __ ] cleaned up she
was a little bitter and whatnot she is
definitely a
different character than the one we saw
last time
i saw a theory online a twitter tweeter
i wish i had copied the
tweet who said uh um
that's not sharon carter that's a scroll
this whole time and it's going to lead
into the you know this
the secret war storyline that they're
talking about doing i was like
i love that that's hot see man like if
that was invincible
nobody would do that speculate they'd
flat out tell you oh this was gonna
happen because i wrote the [ __ ] comma
but with this we could speculate because
they're not doing any story that they've
ever done
previously i mean at least not with this
one i mean there's there's elements like
the
the doctor that dr nagel who's talking
about um
the the blood that they pulled off of um
whatever
subjects is a character from truth red
white and black like that dude was in
the robert morales
kyle baker book really yeah you know and
which
i i should i shouldn't do a mia culpa
it's been a while since i read that book
and i got some [ __ ] wrong last episode
that i would like to cop to in that
isaiah bradley was not the prototype for
steve rogers
he was the the prototype for replicating
erskine's formula like they wanted to
make more super
soldiers they didn't have the the og
digits to make it happen
so they then start just making [ __ ] up
in a lab and
then they tested it first on black
subjects
of which he was one of five who survived
so
it was not pre-steve rogers it's post
steve rogers so i got that wrong
um is that true true i always thought
truth was i
too thought it was pre-steve rogers yeah
as as did i and that's sort of how i
remembered it but doing a little bit
more research
and you know listening to the internet
um
that that is in fact what it was you
know even interviews with robert morales
who who passed away in like 2009 i think
um but he talked about how surprised he
was that marvel let him do that
he always thought that that would be the
one that they shut down like bringing
the steve rogers into it at all
they're like no no we're fine with that
like you can't say that
he was before steve rogers but after
steve rogers yeah we can say that
and so in the book did they send him on
missions that steve
captain america just didn't know about
that was during that period where
captain america was like more of a
showman
before um i if i remember correctly and
again
i didn't reread the book to discover
this stuff but i think it was in the ice
during that time
yeah like the the war still rages post
steve being trapped in the ice
and so i gotta be honest with you i like
our version better
but if it's mine to do i do it this way
but
um all right so um but yes
uh not for my money not enough i i want
to see more
of the isaiah bradley storyline so
hopefully we'll see more of that and
there's only three episodes left right
i know like that's the thing it's like
you know this was the kind of beaten
potatoes of the plot
like we have to move forward into where
we need to be and so
yeah don't worry four five and six we
are going to spend all the money and do
all of this stuff but here's the
sort of the the beginning of act two
like chuff where we gotta find out who
put these krueger items in here
who's that guy like all right the south
africans okay what are we turning like
all of that lethal weapony kind of like
here's the the plot
pipe we need to lay so we can blow some
[ __ ] up later on so we can kill mr
joshua
um in the final reel um or you just
maybe
you you also mixed up your lethal weapon
i did
weapon two right there i did i went mr
joshua
and uh uh the weapon verse
ultimate movie
into the weapon verse where every cast
member can meet across a couple
different departments
where mr joshua can come back and fight
i don't even know who the rest of the
bad guys were
yeah there's endo the asian dude who's
in every movie from the 1980s
um he's also the uh the bad guy in
die hard who reaches for the candy bar
in the in the
yes yes
um all right enough about that [ __ ] um
but yeah
i'm here for it they got three episodes
uh left
and so far so good i enjoy the heck out
of it
um i saw somebody today on twitter was
also like
why you know like uh they thought the
sequence the jail breakout sequence was
like come on
like they felt that was like i guess not
big enough or whatever the [ __ ]
but um i was fine with it i didn't bump
into that i'm like great he gets out
using his wits and [ __ ] look
i just love baron zemo so the fact that
they're you
using them at all the fact that he's
lounging around in an airplane
dressed in [ __ ] purple the fact that
he has that furry collar
on his coat the fact that you know he's
like
uh if it doesn't pass the smell test you
could serve it to these guys anyway
and these [ __ ] butler's like oh i'm
glad you're back sir
it was just [ __ ] awesome and then
seeing him and pull on the [ __ ] mask
and start
firing away and [ __ ] like you know i'm
there for it man
i do love how like at no point when he
was arrested
by the authorities did anybody discover
like
did you know that this guy's a [ __ ]
baron like he's not just like
tommy zeno of the you know sakova zimas
no he's legit royalty should somebody
know that
aren't there laws like aren't there like
diplomatic immunities
i hate to take it right back to legal
weapon but
um all right so that's falcon and the
winter soldier
indeed three in the books for us man
here on fat man beyond
uh they're continuing to to kill it over
there
um in a good way man disney disney will
just
have us you know like three more weeks
of this
then i'm sure there will be the behind
the scenes falcon winter soldiers
special
then we get loki right is
or black widow well black widow's july
i think oh is that right all right
loki's coming up yeah
and then loki's coming up and then black
widow and then
hawkeye and then like they will just
there will never be a time when we're
not talking about something
on disney plus at this rate so smart
once their marvel season
is up then their star wars season kicks
in
yeah bad batch i think is coming in may
um which we get to talk about as well um
if and we want to if and we want to
um i haven't talked about that for sure
absolutely
absolutely i have not seen godzilla v
khan yet
because i'm going to the theater
tomorrow i've watched half of it
yes i have not finished yet but like oh
my god they spent a lot of money
[Laughter]
it is expensive like you know just
it's crazy as you watch it you're like
well that's not real
that's not real that's not real that's
not real
all that [ __ ] had to be made um but
uh yes it's big it's a big ass big ass
movie
outstanding i'm glad i'm spending the
money so far i
i've seen uh a bunch of battles um
and no complaints like they they don't
it's not like they're like we're saving
it for the third act they give you
kong godzilla fighting kong pretty damn
quick
outstanding but once again and i know
i've said this
and people on the internet have
criticized me for it because like the
human element is the most important
element but
man you could keep all those human
scenes and just
just just give me like i'd almost rather
see it from kong's perspective where
he's like i don't know what they're
talking about
i just woke up on a giant boat man i'm
ready to [ __ ] go
uh spoilers i mean i was in the trailer
but like
it's yeah it's yeah i like them to treat
the humans the way that
they treat adults and peanuts
i would take that that'd be amazing i
mean honestly
i was watching it and i was like the
humans in these movies
they must shoot for like a week you're
in and out of this show in like a week
right because
like you're always in a booth somewhere
going like oh godzilla's mad we got to
figure it out and then
you know you do that 10 times and that's
it you're right
yeah yeah you could be that guy to let
them fight guy or a little girl who
loads up like the
little kong doll and stuff like that i'm
telling you i shouldn't be
[ __ ] saying this [ __ ] i should be
trying to get a job in these [ __ ]
movies because
you don't work very long man
like are you going to be the harbinger
guy who says
you're all misunderstanding you're all
not you don't understand what's about to
happen
we're smarter not harder kids yes
be a human in one of those titan movies
you know you work a week you get your
hospitalization your medical covered for
you
uh but i will watch the rest of it i i
have uh mark is gonna go see it he's
saving it he's gonna see it on a big
screen
rich man rented out movie theater and
[ __ ] like that he's got those bernard
mega bucks bernardin as you know
means wealthy so it does
it's what i like to call white boy money
money i've been looking for my whole
life met a few
met a few white boys and they had it
sadly
money but uh but yeah tomorrow night i'm
going to the theater to watch it so i'll
report back
next week right on i uh i watched on my
big ass
tv and from my bed and i was very
very content but i fell asleep watching
it not because it was boring just
because it was two in the morning no it
was like
my wife was like don't you think it's
too late to start this i'm like no way
man no way
it's a clash of
they gave me so much titan fighting
right up top that by midway through i
was like
not because i was bored but just because
i was like all right i came i got what i
came here for
i'm spent i'll watch the rest in the
morning night nights no go back to
monster hub later
it is uh it's monster hub it is uh it's
available to watch right now kids and
probably the story of the week
naturally which will be the story for us
next week because
uh i'll finish it and mark will watch it
and boy oh boy
we'll be all over kong's dong that's for
sure indeed
um okay this is the part of the show
where we get to the god damn news
mark bernardin is a news hound ladies
and gentlemen he's many
things but he started in the in the
black and white
news mills back east man putting words
together
on blocks so they can run it on giant
printing presses he's a new sound
he always goes out and finds the news
for us mark bernard has the news what's
the news mark
um before i get into the news that i
found i want to hear about the news that
you said you found
um which you were like all over twitter
today a thing was we're talking about
we're going to get into it
what did you see today that was on
twitter that we're going to oh uh that
they're not making the new gods
that is news number one excellent just
making sure i didn't miss a thing
no i think that was it i was so shocked
by that the ava duvernay
new gods movie they've put on hold um i
was
i was surprised but less shocked by the
announcement that uh they're putting the
the uh the trench movie on hold i just
watched
aquaman with uh jen the other night man
and that's a [ __ ] long movie man boy
there's a lot of movie in that like
it really does feel like they were like
we're only ever gonna get to make one
aquaman movie across
all of the multiverse let's put
everything in it and they [ __ ] did it
really delivers it's just so [ __ ]
packed
so as we were watching it like you know
when the trench scene happened i was
like oh yeah they're making this movie
next and then all of a sudden today
they're like
now we ain't making that movie um
surprising because you could make that
whole trench movie without using like
[ __ ]
famous people or expensive people just a
bunch of
you know [ __ ] fish creatures and [ __ ]
so anyway warner brothers announced
they're not making that
at least at the present and they also
announced more shockingly
that they're not making new gods with uh
ava and
who was tom king was working on king was
writing that was writing it with her
who wrote the uh mr miracle series
fairly recently so he's their new gods
guy
but this project seemed like it was a
done deal
like powerhouse talent behind it
um having a woman direct this giant
sprawling [ __ ]
epic on of of the uh of jack kirby's
fourth world uh [ __ ] you know uh
apocalypse and new genesis like
this is gonna be huge and all of a
sudden they're like we're not gonna do
it right now
did they say why and they didn't
according to the
to the statement released by warner
brothers in dc films
as part of our dc slate some legacy
development titles including new gods in
the trench will not be moving forward
we thank our partners ava duvernay tom
king james wan and peter safran
for their time in collaboration during
this process and look forward to our
continued partnership with them on other
dc stories
the projects will remain in their
skillful hands if they were to move
forward in the future
um so yeah there is no official
statement as to why
um the sort of conventional popular
theory is
that new gods just didn't fit in with
their idea of the dc films going forward
and i think that they are trying to hew
very closely to the multiverse idea um
given that like yes we're getting the
flash is going to spin force
for their multi-universe in a big bad
way but looking at
different various iterations on ip that
we understand and know and are invested
in which is we get more batman's we get
more jokers we get more
shazams and aquamans and all that stuff
can kind of live and and who knows what
the third wonder woman movie will be
but they're trying to build a cohesive
multiverse around
ultimately the characters from the
justice league um and now some of the
characters in justice league dark as
we're gonna see it's
a tana movie and like there's there's
lots of other stuff happening and the
new gods
always felt separate and beyond from
that like that
doesn't tie in to our mainline superhero
world at all um you know except
for as much as zack snyder's justice
league was like hey we're all about
these new gods like let's
introduce granny goodness and dark side
and decide on all these
these creatures we just got a nice taste
of it where it's like oh [ __ ] we're
headed to the fourth world and now all
of a sudden they're like yeah
that's it we don't want to go to the
fourth world um
so yeah it's it's unclear why i i don't
know if
it's a matter of they'd had their fill
of the new gods
in in justice league and like hey we we
tried
we gave it a valiant effort twice um and
we feel like we've told as much of that
story as we want to
or hey it's not dead it's just not
the the right time to to get into the
fourth world for now
um but yeah i mean they have let's see
they're they're slate as far as we know
it uh suicide squad
on august 6th batman march 4th 2022
black adam july 29
2022 um the flash
on november 4th 2022 which will then
spin out
into aquaman 2 shazam few of the gods in
2023 blue beetles supergirl
uh green lantern core and static shock
along with
zetana the tana housing coach jj abrams
superman
and wonder woman three uh good heavens
that's a packed slate
that is a lot of stuff and i guess they
just sort of felt that
you know that
maybe there's not room for stuff like a
weird side adventure in the trench
and with you know a weird distant
um trans-dimensional
blah blah of new gods um so who knows
they're not wrong on the trench and as
much as like
why spend money and time developing ip
that's not
like you know about ragman about the
spectre like they got a treasure trove
of characters that they could create
stories with rather than like hey
remember these side characters that were
in [ __ ] aquaman that could be a whole
thing
it's like wow how about instead of that
we do
you know i don't know [ __ ] um
i mean i mean there's also be like let's
do an hbo max 25 million dollar horror
movie called the trench
which is about these monsters who live
in the bottom of the ocean who like do
some awful [ __ ] like yeah
james one seems like the guy who could
wrap his head around that
but as a big ass kind of super heroey
thing
it's probably not the right formulation
of events for them
um well it's a shame uh particularly for
the new gods cause
you know [ __ ] that'd be that'd be lovely
to see
and perhaps one day we will but right
now ain't happening kids
indeed um we like to give you good news
on this show
you know not like that john krasinski
good news
can't all be bunnies and [ __ ] puppies
but we like to be good news about the
future on this show
unfortunately there's some bad news
about the future we're not going to get
a [ __ ] uh
a dark side movie you know what we are
gonna get though
a live-action thundercats movie the [ __ ]
seriously seriously who's doing this
what brave souls entering there
uh the brave soul is the fellow who just
left the ring with godzilla versus kong
director adam wingard
another guy who pong skull island um no
that was uh
jordan roberts so then who's the guy who
just did this
uh this one adam wingard what has he
done before
um he done some sort of um kind of
smaller
horror stuff i think he did a film
called you're next oh yeah yeah
yeah he did a a live-action adaptation
of death note
um but yeah like apparently he's loved
the thundercats
since they were young kittens um
and uh and he he just sort of like came
out and said hey man
here's what i want to do next he's using
the animated series as a jumping off
point but then he will take it in the
direction he's been thinking about
for many years in a sort of hybrid cg
animation
jammy jam i mean in a world where they
made
cats you can get away with thundercats
you know what i'm saying
like you can you don't even have to just
make them up
per se you can [ __ ] cg their
feline features and whatnot put
buttholes on them like they did with one
of those cuts of cats
if this isn't the [ __ ] cut of the
[ __ ] thundercats then what are we
here for
um let me tell you something right now
i'm [ __ ] there for mamra
mumra the ever living um well that's
good news for somebody
i look i'll watch it i was never a
thundercat's kid
that was uh i was kind of already in
high school when thundercats broke
um but uh you know i'm there for it i
support it i'm not against it but i
stretch the imagination
now i know this is going to make a bunch
of [ __ ] people happy i know a lot of
people
uh or i don't know this for a fact but
i've seen some people on the internet
aren't very happy with the current
thundercats cartoon
um they think it's a little too animated
or whatever the hell
right um sounds like they're gonna get
everything they want with a live action
movie
who's doing it what studio um
let's see i think it's going to be it
feels like it's going to be
warner brothers um but it's fun to do
the cartoon right because i see
it on the warner brothers lot the big
thundercats billboard
yeah i mean it's not it wasn't made
clear in the news story but
you know which perhaps it is just a
bunch of production companies now
without a studio involved but
mark who am i who am i i'm one of the
cows and it's a small world after all
[Laughter]
i appreciate you not waiting for an
answer because i never would have gotten
there
[Laughter]
uh all right what other news what other
news um
disney plus our friends at disney plus
let me tell you about the disney
plus can sleep with my wife if if disney
plus wants to because they're doing me
right
everywhere oh there's this disney plus i
had no idea
that i would enjoy it as much as i do
aside from giving us these cool new
shows they you know i could deep dive
and watch every simpsons but did you
know they put together this like
star wars vintage category i just saw
that today
did you and it has like the ewok movies
in it and the cartoons and [ __ ] like
that mm-hmm
um i even that i was like now that's
[ __ ] fan service good for them
and no wonder they got like all those
people buying in because i'm a happy
customer i'm sure everyone else as long
as they keep giving us the good
good man brand new show every [ __ ]
other month or whatever the [ __ ] they
can have me
indeed um but they have confirmed the
cast
for the new star wars series obi-wan
kenobi that was big news this week i saw
this [ __ ] that was some big news
and so joel edgerton and buddy bonnie
pais
she was the lady who was in that
documentary to vow
indeed i was like okay you watched that
documentary you were like well
that star wars was the one bright moment
in her
career and it'll never come again cut
two
they're like come on back we need aunt
peru and uncle owen
yeah she's playing the long game i'm
like you just wait they're gonna come
back
they're gonna ask me again and i'm going
to be ready yeah man it's good thing
that she ain't in that cult no more and
[ __ ]
next year
um well that's uh yeah i saw those two
are coming back
the one that [ __ ] blew my mind is one
of the safety brothers is
is in the cab benny saftey is in the
cast [ __ ]
good time man o'shea jackson jr
mm-hmm i spoke to his dad this week on
uh
on smodcast did he have feelings about
his son going into a galaxy far far away
i didn't know they announced it the next
day but what was horrible is him and i
were zooming
and in the corner of the zoom how it has
your name like mine says kevin smith
it said oh period jackson and then for
a while i was like oh wow in his real
life he actually goes by his name but
then i started thinking
as we were halfway through the zoom i
bet you he's on his kid's computer
you know what i'm saying like he's an
old man like me so i'm sure he's just
like get in here and get me on your
laptop
yeah make the talking box work
brilliant genius responsible for like
some of the greatest rap songs of all
time
some of the greatest movies comedies of
all time and whatnot and i'm like i bet
you he can't figure out his laptop
yeah it's like why can't i i can't hear
him
why can't i hear him oh junior get your
ass in here and put me on the zoom
so uh junior who he doesn't go by that
at all i'm sure
does he uh not as far as i know i don't
think anybody's calling him junior
um not to his face anyway um he's in the
cast
he's in the cast kumar nanjiani is in
the cast
that was that was new information i mean
look a lot of this was new information
but some of the roles we'd heard about
along the way
yeah but that was brand new india of
armor rupert
which mail are they putting in the
camail we all know
or [ __ ] cut from god's own marble
look at the veins and the sinew look at
look at the
look at the [ __ ] strength in this
comic or is it that camille
um i i think that camel is the only
command you get
man oh man because i remember i was
listening to the podcast that he did
with his wife emily gordon
um at the sort of beginning of the
pandemic and he just was talking about
how now like working out for him is just
a way of life
and it's how he was finding his center
and he just he feels compelled to do it
and maybe it's once marvel spends that
money to get you in that shape
you're like i'm not gonna [ __ ] this up
if all i gotta do is work out and like
eat
pretty decently like i'm gonna stay like
this
also because you're like you know it
ain't just they don't just do one of
these marvel movies there's probably
gonna be a few eternals
yeah and so now he's also gonna be in a
star wars picture so
maybe those he's putting those guns to
good use
good for him who else um let's see lady
from rome who they already announced
yeah indira varma um rupert friend
sung kang who means nothing to you but
to anybody who's seen a fast and furious
movie
he plays my favorite character name in
the entire
series han solo
is literally the character's name it's
han and then it's soe
s o e u l hyphen o h
that's q so he's han solo um
simone kessel and benny safty
big cass they didn't say what their
storyline they're doing
they said nothing oh and hayden
christensen is back as darth vader
that's the channel then he's gonna play
darth vader yeah
yeah yeah his you know and whether or
not we get to see force ghosty
um you know anybody whether or not
there's
a version of obi-wan communing
with his old friend who's now become his
new enemy so we get to see
actual anakin skywalker again or we
might get see a little qui-gon action in
this as well
indeed because that was his mission
right was to like you know protect the
boy and i'll teach you how to commune
with the dead
yes okay you know or you know you're
getting a little qui-gon action in this
there ain't no way
that he ain't their [ __ ] you know
mark hamill in the final episode where
it's like
qui-gon well
liam neeson came back look who banffed
in ladies and gentlemen our resident
star wars expert what do you have to say
liam neeson had come back in star wars
rebels
i believe to do a voice cameo
so it would make sense they've already
got him for the coach
rise of skywalker right well he did it
in
in rebels he actually they animated him
and he voiced it
um i'm not sure in rise of skywalker
they pulled voices from everybody
but i don't know if they re recorded
them
where i think that was new if i remember
the story correctly it was new and even
beyond that
they shot him like it wasn't just meant
to be a voiceover
oh to see force ghosts
and i think they sh i mean this could be
sacral
not sex what do they call it um not when
it's sacral uh
apocryphal but i'm pretty damn sure that
like what i read that
he had shot people as these
like he shot hayden and he shot um
uh liam neeson but then instead they
just went with
their voices voices the um the other
interesting thing is that
hayden is kind of the first anakin that
actually gets to play darth vader it's
always been a
david prowse or a stunt double or
whatever it is and you're gonna actually
see
anakin play vader which is kind of
interesting
what are they gonna do about the voice
though is gonna be james earl jones you
think
i'm probably not i mean they got him for
rogue one
but then they well they got him for you
know [ __ ] the last of the prequels
when he was like you know where's padme
and then she's like she died
no so they've established
that he sounds like james earl jones
from the moment a guy got off the table
so i feel like
it's got to be james earl jones right um
he's old i mean that's that's the thing
in uh coming to america yeah
yeah like i mean he can still do it
clearly
but you know that's uh
that's a big that's a big ask for that
dude
dude it's a big ass to get him but like
if it's not him that's
massive news in the star wars universe
that would be the first time
that james old jones wasn't voicing
darth vader well and how do you justify
that if he's around and
and working like he just did coming to
america too how do you not
just get him in a vo booth for an
afternoon
or in front of a zoom you know
yeah again for the lion king that just
came out not too long ago
um but he's 90 years old um
is he really yeah he's as old as william
shatner
yeah william shatner just turned nine to
this week and that blew my hair back i'm
like
90. you really don't look it like he
looks like
70s max but like of the two of them that
i expected to be better preserved it was
not
william shet agreed
um so yes we we we have a cast for for
kenobi
cameras roll this month apparently
sometime in april
um i it seems as if their their process
is about a year from cameron's role to
air
so it looks as if april 2022 perhaps is
when we get kenobi
something to live for kids something to
look forward to something to believe in
as the good folks at poison used to sing
to us
indeed indeed so yes that is a good
thing
um did this was one of the
the the oddest news stories of the week
and yet made all the sense in the world
game of thrones you know beloved fantasy
project um
shepherded created by and now sort of
creatively god fathered by george rr
martin
uh looks like it's going to the stage
to the broadway a live
show a dramatic stage show spectacular
based on george rr martin's fantasy
world
is now in development musical or
non-musical non-musical
um the the the first show is expected to
launch in 2023.
um the production includes a fairly
unique story element that should be a
huge draw for fans
um most of the shows that they're now
developing for hbo max are prequels that
won't involve
very many of the original characters um
this as yet untitled plays set during a
pivotal moment in westeros history
the great tourney and harrenhal a
contest that took place just 16 years
before the events in game of thrones
um so it is entirely possible that you
could see
young ned stark um you know his
sister lyanna lord rabbit baratheon
cocky teenage jamie lannister
love struck prince rhaegar targaryen
prince oberyn martel
all of these characters that we've seen
in the show just 10 or 15 years
before we we've seen them so
it's a pretty big deal like it's a legit
dramatic
enterprise that's set in a singular
location
um that could also feel a bit like
medieval times there's jousting and
archery
and also maybe incest so
you muted dude
i said just like at medieval times kids
incest
um wow that's i
not what i would do but not undoable
but you know i guess the model is uh you
know the harry potter and the cursed
child right
like they did a whole [ __ ] play
that's made a bunch of money and [ __ ]
and could become a thing later on after
it's done with its
live run and stuff but so i i guess
stranger things have happened but
yeah you know it's it's it's weird but
not
it's not the craziest idea that i'd
heard and i think to your point the
harry potter
show is very much the the the if not
inspiration
the comp the comparison that you would
use which is
they made a boatload of money off of
that yeah
you know and that show can play and will
play
whenever theaters return for a good long
time
you know and as could this there's if
this is good
there's no reason why it couldn't play
you know touring companies all over the
world
it's a popular book
i heard somebody upstairs
um sorry ghost here's something out
above me and i thought
jen was down for the count now i'm like
who's upstairs
um well i you know
normally i'm like well you know i i'll
see it i don't know if i will see that
not because i'm like i'm against it i'm
just like
i don't know i mean i don't know
i guess i guess we'll have to see yeah
it's it's very early stages
you know if it happens at all it won't
for b for another couple of years at
best
feels a little late no well i mean
i i think that they are they are
foreseeing
a new wave of interest in game of
thrones i think they're hoping
that the new hbo max show slash shows
will will sort of re-engineer some
interest in it
at some point george rr martin will
finish his final book which will be
a sort of pop phenomenon of the he
finally did it you guys
he finished the books um so if
that entire sort of collection of events
begins to to get some traction then yeah
maybe a stage play
is not the weirdest thing so i had to
text my wife to be like are you on the
deck
um i don't know she hasn't texted back
kevin we haven't had a deck in 40 years
yeah the call is coming from inside the
deck
get out of the house
um okay if i if i uh hopefully i don't
get killed and if i do it's on camera
because that'd be huge for the show i'm
sure um
but frightening but massive nobody's
coming in this room with this [ __ ]
ring light on for like no way
it's true i can't do crimes in the
bright light
light on my crimes what else we got uh
the last story of the day
um which is tangentially genre but you
know we talked about
the first of the what is not going to be
at least three movies
so why not talk about it here netflix is
closing in on a deal to make
two sequels to ryan johnson's 2019 hit
knives out
now who made the first one was that fox
it was lionsgate
um mrc was the studio and they paid for
it and it was distributed through
lionsgate
but they didn't make any other deals it
was a single picture by picture basis
and so they were now free to do whatever
they wanted to do with the sequels
and so apparently they went to town
and you know apple and amazon were were
other
uh potential bidders on it but it
went to netflix for some 450 million
dollars is what it's going to cost them
to acquire produce and then release
these two more
knives out in movies i never understand
these figures does that mean that
ryan johnson gets 400 million dollars
no i i don't think so um i think that
you know i i don't think that's just the
rights to acquire
the rights to make a movie um i imagine
that part of that was hey
it cost us 40 million dollars to make
the first one let's pretend it'll cost
us 80 million dollars to make the next
two
everything beyond that production cost
then becomes profit for us
um because they think that the
viewership and the subscription bumps
and all that stuff will be worth it
um but it's a great deal for ryan
johnson then it means that we get to see
more more daniel craig is benwa
blanc and it's all different cass right
it's like he's
he's like his sherlock holmes he'll just
take him through different things
yeah he's he's your hercule puerto or
he's your whatever it's it's
very much agatha christie here's your
gentleman detective
who's embroiled in a different set of
murders
um 400 million mark is an incredible
amount of money for two movies that
don't really have special effects in
them
if they're anything like the first one
you know what i'm saying it's not like
400 million dollars that's two marvel
movies
so like where's all the money going man
like hopefully people are getting well
paid because
it's they're literally just talky
detective pictures i'm not reducing them
saying they suck you know knives out was
wonderful but i'm just saying
400 million dollars for like people
talking to each other
somebody better be getting rich off this
sounds like
part of the deal is like not just this
is what we use to make the movie but
like
here's the riches for being knives out
two and three because knives out one did
so well
yeah guys that one cost 40 million to
make and made 300
odd million dollars um and for a movie
that to your point is
the oldest of old school kinds of movies
which is a bunch of people in a house
talking at each other one of which may
be a murderer and one of which is
eventually going to be dead um
you know and uh and to be able to just
yeah we can this is a formula that yeah
agave christie
kept on printing and repeating all the
gun and doyle just like hey man yeah no
we're going to do
murderly express and death on the nile
and
and and any number of different books so
why can't we
so if you liked that movie um you have
two more to look forward to at some
point in the next few years
um good for him man he's such a sweet
kid and like you know
there's something to be said for like
that's his baby
all of that is his he was like i want to
do like a detective
thing now he's got himself a [ __ ]
franchise and mind you
he worked on a franchise a little called
star wars
once and once upon a time so it must be
incredibly satisfying for him to be like
i got my own thing
you know yeah and it seems like this
deal he could have done it with brick he
could have made a brick universe as well
but probably smarter to do with daniel
craig
and i think that you know he was i
speaking for him
i'm gonna say he was inspired by the
deal that george lucas made on the first
star wars
which is yeah no i'll make this movie
for you
but the sequel rights belong to me and
that's when i get rich
that's when i cash in and so like yeah
i'll make this movie for you
mrc and and lionsgate but i get the
right to make the next ones my own
uh er mixon's craziest theories
in chat mark on youtube says seriously
how do you a director not know this
stuff
you literally make movies for a living
why would i know about making
200 million movies or deals like this
i've never had a deal like this in my
life
kids they don't give away deals like
this all the time that's why it's news
if they did this all the time they
wouldn't [ __ ] write about it but
a guy gets 400 million dollars for a
couple sequels and
i'm supposed to know anything about it
i'm lucky to get two
two [ __ ] nickels to put together to
make a [ __ ] movie and stuff so
this is news to me just because you're a
director don't mean you know every
aspect of the [ __ ] business
i ain't you know never been to the halls
of power or anything like that
such a weird thing to be like you're a
director how do you not know this i'm
like
i don't know you're a human being how do
you not know everything to know about
human beings like
you you [ __ ] stick to your corner man
you do your thing in your
backyard and [ __ ] why am i explaining
myself to that dude
anyway um ooh somebody in chat joel says
uh jessica walters news about her death
we should talk about her
uh yes she figures into our
into the genre world of course through
uh by way of archer she played archer's
mom
um but uh and our genre thriller genre
if you go back to play misty for me
um also uh the comedic genre
of course uh for like brilliant
performance
across many seasons of uh arrested
development
um lucille bluth uh
one of the greatest tv characters ever
created but had everything to do with
the performer
planner i think i think i think lucille
bluth got bigger
because jessica walter could give so
much
and showing the writers and directors
enough where they're like right to that
right to that
so uh a huge [ __ ] huge loss
first time i ever noticed her was in the
mad magazine movie up the academy
um where ron liebman her husband uh was
in it
as well and he propositioned her in the
movie he's like
tickle your ass with a feather and she's
like what'd you say he's like
particularly nice weather
um but i've i remember seeing them
together on an episode of law and order
years ago
as well um you know he's passed a couple
years ago
if i remember correctly um is a shame to
lose her man she was
really cool classy funny talented lady
never met her but
[ __ ] loved her worked yeah now she
passed on wednesday the 24th at 80 years
old
80. she should have kept going she
should have those shatner years those
shatner james earl jones years
90. g gordon liddy died this week he was
also 90.
you know 90. 90s the new 70. apparently
man
apparently you know like i sit here at
50 and i'm like well
my life i probably have less years in
front of me than behind me but who knows
man if people are living in 90 and [ __ ]
like that stan made it to like what 96
yeah i mean carl reiner was like 97
98 maybe you could do it
i mean look roman lee is still kicking
he's like 104. that's absolutely right
um all right is that the end of the news
that's the end of the news my friend
the mind fornicator says george siegel
also i we talked about him last week
didn't we
i thought we did i think we did too yeah
um i know i talked about him on some
like someplace else maybe hollywood
babylon but i loved
george siegel i got to preside over his
uh his uh
star ceremony in the hollywood walk of
fame
i let him on the goldbergs and and we
got along very well and he was like come
come do uh come do my swearing-in
ceremony
i'm sure we talked about this here maybe
not maybe i you know i do a lot of
talking kids so
sometimes i forget where that's all the
news we got
that's all the news my friend last
chance kids anyone want to give us any
[ __ ] news before we get out here or
anything we missed you can hit me in
chat right now
because if not we're moving on we're
moving on to the q a part of the goddamn
show
yep um all right i see nothing
so we're it looks like we're free to go
uh
move on to the next section the final
section of our show
uh ladies and gentlemen hold on we got
breaking news from chat mark i knew
they would come through for us john
zannorini says my mom was working at the
monroeville mall while you were filming
zach and miri
that's it big news that's the that's the
tweet
thank you that was good big news about
zack's mom
uh 37-47 carlin in chat
guesses that the power broker did
mandarin
which could set you up for shang chi
which is coming up
very much
what else can we uh have uh nothing else
who should
well these are questions all right so
michael ellidge just let us know that he
just farted thank you michael
excellent open a window yeah late
breaking news
i broke it or some [ __ ] um all right
that's it for all the news now we're
heading into the q a portion of the show
ladies and gentlemen so we
beg jc to bamf in here and [ __ ]
give us what you um well because we
talked about pizza
for a while today uh
vickishd was wondering if you guys
opened a restaurant which
superheroes would you hire for each of
the different
positions in a restaurant oh my
wait are we into it this is the first
question yeah
did you want a little banter or
something oh usually you're like
warm us up you tell us what's going on
in chat somewhere diving right into it
you skip the kiss and you're right
i was excited for tickling your taint
you just want to ask a question i was
about to grab a quick [ __ ]
okay and all these questions were coming
at me fast and furious
don't you have any don't you have any
like chit chat you can
[ __ ] kill some time what's been going
on in chat tell us about that
the uh we got the um
some people called it out in chat we got
the the original
2d clone wars micro series on that
vintage
uh disney plus uh they came back
that was pretty exciting because it was
hard to find right like you couldn't you
couldn't buy those anywhere
yeah they they stopped making the dvds
you couldn't buy them so it was kind of
like
you know if you knew somebody who had it
it was like pornography when you were a
kid you knew the one guy
whose parents had showtime and taped
something off of it that's kind of how
that dvd was for a while
um so we got that back which was kind of
cool
chat's been pretty good no uh
why we're not talking about superman and
lois they've now went on a hiatus so we
should probably
watch those episodes and talk about
those
uh next week supergirl is now back in
its place for a little while but
uh i've heard nothing but good things
about uh superman and
and lois yeah i just did it it slipped
through the cracks and then finding it
on the other side of those cracks
um will just take some doing but but
it's one of those is this an hbo max it
should be on hbo max and the answer is
no it's not an hbo max i'm like well
where can i watch it
i think i found out but still did we
talk about
dr fate last week or no we did last week
yeah
did as well all right so chat some
people are going what about this
um wyatt russell asks a question in chat
and i'm sure
i'm sure it's not the white russell but
he asks why did zemo put on his mask to
kill three people and take it back off
i took had that moment as well because i
was like he put it on
and then like a few minutes later he
took it off
so i don't i didn't understand the
rationale but i was more than happy to
see him in that [ __ ] mask
and also like it was the mask in some
way
and why was it just hanging out on the
seat of it like 1983 dusseldorf supreme
or whatever don't give a [ __ ] i was glad
it exists
[ __ ] all those logic questions i was
just happy when i went to prison i was
masturbating in this mask and here's
what i left it so
i i gotta get a thing it looks like it's
meant to be
like a face shield like bulletproof
right like
where else would he wear it like other
than i'm going to get into some [ __ ]
so i'm going to put on the mask that way
if somebody shoots me it's
that's the logic leaf that i made
because that's the only reason i have no
other armor
just this awesome shearling coat but my
face is protected because this is the
money maker
baby because he's a [ __ ] baron kids
he's a goddamn baron
baron zemo um all right now i'm ready jc
okay um so we talked about pizza
and vicki's d was wondering if you guys
opened a restaurant
fully staffed with superheroes who would
you hire for
each of the different positions so you
need a
cook a bartender a server
and a door guy if we were gonna staff
scum and villainy that's what we do
okay minimum okay we hit
we'll go one we'll go position for
position hit us with that list again
okay so uh we'll start at the front door
who would be your door guy
um the incredible hulk
um
[Music]
swam thing mine would be uh
you're gonna get into a [ __ ]
philosophical conversation with the
bouncer
well i don't want somebody who like has
rage control problems
you want a bouncer who's got a slightly
more even keel
good point he's just like i would let
you in but the green
yes answer me these questions three and
into you may
uh fair enough i buy that jc who was
yours i like uh gorilla grodd
good call man it's entertaining because
people are like did you see the gorilla
speak
like he's talking to us and crazy [ __ ]
inspired by
who framed roger rabbit right they had a
very effective door guy
all right what's the next position chef
uh
yeah uh cook a cook
cookie say um
well
reed richards
because not only is he brilliant and
he'll have a lot of recipes and [ __ ] but
he can work by himself in the kitchen
he can get the salt if it's way over
there
you know he's like an octopus man so
he's my chef what about you he's my cook
um i feel like doctor strange would be a
good cook
i feel like you know [ __ ] he's a dude
who reads real fast
so has read every cookbook in the world
can conjure magical ingredients and [ __ ]
to make stuff good
and uh and even though he can no longer
uh perform surgery on people i don't
think those knife skills are entirely
gone
it's true man that did be good with
[ __ ] chopping up them carrots all
right just [ __ ]
he can astrally project himself into the
kitchen he could be having a
conversation with you in one room
cooking in the other
he could be front of house and back of
house oh
that's good what about you jc who's your
chef i liked uh
either quicksilver or the flash because
they could zip around and
have everything going and multitask but
i think
fast doesn't mean good though
yeah but you can turn the orders out
fair enough
the uh i think the best though wt frocks
in chat pointed out condiment king would
be good
in the kitchen absolutely what a great
call
um all right so we got our our our bar
our doorman our chef bartender we need a
bartender
i choose jesus this is a man who could
take water and turn it into wine
you know and who's a what what bigger
superhero than jesus
the perfect answer for this good friday
sir thank you that's right
think of think of him on good friday
jesus
jesus uh i go um professor x
i think a good psychic bartender who
knows exactly what you need to drink
without you having to ask for it would
be a popular feature
you could have a whole conversation with
them and you could go deep
and not even talk out loud yep he
he could read your order from the table
you wouldn't even need to get up to go
to the bar
yeah like suddenly just drinks show up
and he could read what's wrong with you
or what what you're going through
help you out get you out of jams and
[ __ ] like that
he's talented this bartender
i like i i think he's i would like you
to find a psychic bartender jc
i uh my thought was uh
if i wasn't using him in the kitchen i
think the flash
would make a good bartender he's a
chemist an answer for everything you're
like
he's a chemist you know he worked in a
chemistry crime lab so he understands
how certain
things go together and he's quick he's
like look
man nobody knows this but a little
formaldehyde
that's going to make them [ __ ] up
um who else we got we need one more
position
uh servers server
uh jamie madrox the multiple man ooh
smart one or duplicate
from invincible if we're going to be a
little more current indeed
after seeing the uh the rebellion
trailer
for suicide squad um that james gunn so
wisely released on april fool's day
i was like arms off man might be
interesting
um as a server but um
i think dazzler i want [ __ ] roller
skates
give me the give me the skates and she
can sing too
and you can sing or jubilee would be
great on karaoke nights
yes um jubilee
she could bring you your drink and then
shoot fireworks
yeah every day is your birthday at
jubilee's pub
that's awesome uh what about you jc
who's your servator
uh similar to you made a [ __ ] flash
again
well similar to your reed richards in
the kitchen i thought plastic man
who seems jovial would be a good uh
server elo brian man i'd take a drink
from him
he's absolutely jovial and like even if
people get shitty drunk and try to punch
him in the face it's just like
comes right out
refill your water from across the
restaurant while he's taking somebody
else's
order this good point
all right we love it that's a great
question well done man
question two um john carlos mcmaster was
asking uh if the marvel or dc
universes were to make a freaky friday
style
body swap comedy what two characters
would you cast
to body swap well dc of course it would
have to be batman and superman you're
big too
uh they couldn't be more unalike yet
while still being kind of you know
similar in some degrees and whatnot
um i you know clark kent
um being a sunshiny
[ __ ] bruce wayne and batman and
[ __ ] bruce wayne inhabiting a very
[ __ ]
dark and emo superman i think would be
fun to watch on the dc
side uh on the marvel side
here i'll think about my marvel side you
go for your dc side mark
um okay dc
uh i instead i go batman and robin
i go batman and dick grayson i think the
classic freaky friday of you know grown
up little kid
swapping places um especially if you do
it early in their run
so it's it's still kind of very young
dick grayson who was broke as [ __ ] who
now gets to be the richest man in gotham
and also a grown-up who's got hair and
funny places and all that [ __ ]
and then batman having to be a child
again but the angriest [ __ ] kid
you've ever met
um that i it's because it's comedy that
you're looking for and i think that
that that uh that particular pairing is
a
is a recipe for dilemmas and delight
[Music]
let's see on the marvel side
a really [ __ ] boring flip freaky
friday
is uh hulk and she-hulk
so essentially it's just like each one
gets to find out what it's like to live
as the other sex
right and also like i have to i practice
law
i've never passed the ball that's true
that's true well i
think we'd use smart hulk but you're
right much better if it's old hulk and
stuff rachel jumped into court he's just
like you know oak smash
and [ __ ] like that um
uh who's yours who's your marvel switch
up um
you know i kind of go the the classic um
power man and iron fist
um i think that that you know it
leaving aside the potential for racial
commentary
um i think it's just funny if those two
guys are suddenly swapping bodies and
you get some of that
you know class difference like so this
is what it's like to be rich and also
i know kung fu and also why don't i know
kung fu i spent [ __ ]
like i stole the heart of the dragon
kunlun and i'm the
no you're just a bruiser now dude you
just gotta punch people real hard
um i think that can that can be kind of
fun and then i also
thought about like wolverine and cyclops
um so wolverine could finally know what
it's like to love gene
and not be loved back by g
but also be stuck in that body that he
hates so much
yeah every time he looks in the mirror
he wants to punch himself
yeah and he just keeps shooting himself
in the face
he keeps trying to break off his
adamantium claws and ship
and horrors and whatnot uh what about
you jc you got any
i think uh the movie i actually really
want to see
is like iron man three and a half which
is
where tony swaps with that little boy
and the little boy gets to be
iron man and tony has to you know be the
sidekick gadget kid
nice one of hot men one and a half iron
man
well it's one environment it's kind of
like vice versa
with judge reinhold and fred savage from
back in the day
right you just literally take the same
guy but
switch ages nice um that was fun
all right [ __ ] that uh take us to our
third
and final question think of something
i was trying to do like spider-man but
they've already done that
like [ __ ] doc ock was spider-man at
one point
like in his head or his body or whatever
the [ __ ]
and uh craven to some degree also was
like
you know they didn't truly freaky friday
it but he pretended to be [ __ ]
spiderman
right well spiderman kingpin would be
fun yes
yes giant man in a little boy's body
thinks he has all the power in the world
and [ __ ]
yeah and then peter trying to be agile
and that clunky massive frame
yeah just just kingpin having to deal
with aunt may
without giving up the ghost so you want
me to fold my clothes woman do you all
know who i
am
peter you're awfully temperamental today
yes oh who's the kingpin now
um all right final question in the
evening so uh frip
25 asked and i've seen this one going
around the internet but i think it could
be fun
uh what movie would you want to see
redone
with muppets and what muppets
would you put in the leading roles
so it's not you don't leave one guy it's
a whole new muppet movie
but you can they can borrow
from whatever movie you're doing muppet
treasure island or muppet wizard of oz
um muppet
seven
playing my parts what's in the box
um let's see who's playing my brad pitt
part
um scooter nice
um but obviously a more confident
scooter than we ever saw
and my morgan freeman
character is
sam the eagle
and the gwyneth paltrow character is
um janice hey man
you know from the [ __ ] doctor teeth
why do you want to leave here mr
summerset what's wrong with this city
um nobody's going to watch my version of
seven with the muppets if i go with sam
the eagle and [ __ ] scooter let me
just
if i can recast with more beloved
muppets
fozzie's not ripe for anything in
seven except maybe like the the heavyset
guy that they've
who eats the spaghetti and [ __ ] dies
right um
i mean i maybe maybe no kermit
kermit's not right for either part
well kermit's john doe
[Music]
oh that's good you're right i forgot
about him kermit spacey kermit spacey
kermit um that's a good call man
where he's like hi ho look at all my
notebooks
i surrendered to you become
wrath yay
[Laughter]
all right you know what i'm buying this
if kermit is our [ __ ] killer
we get away with scooter and sam the
eagle not the sexiest
cast but people are like what kermit is
the bad guy
[ __ ] i'm in what a spin nice
all right what's yours um i'm going
um trading places
uh i think
i might also have to do sam the eagle
for for dan
aykroyd for lewis winforp
sam sam [ __ ] eagle getting a lot of
play in our world he needs
he needs uh us to be his agents [ __ ] i
think so we're getting a lot more work
um dr teeth is billy ray valentine
nice um um walter and statloff or
are the duke brothers clearly
um waldorf and stadler i don't know what
i just said
um
i think i think you have to go miss
piggy
as uh as jamie lee curtis
yeah agreed um
don't janice that one no like it's it's
easy to go
janus but i but i think i think you want
you want piggy
front and center in this you want a star
yeah
and uh and i think maybe kermit is is
beaks
is a is uh is the
is the is the evil sort of shady
operator
the one who winds up with in the with
the with the gorilla
yeah the the weird-ass bestiality scene
at the end of that movie that's played
for laughs
he's the same guy who is like you mess
with the bull you get the horns
right yep absolutely who raided barry
manilow's wardrobe
um what a wonderful character actor he
was i like it i
i'll pay uh where's my money here you go
i would watch both of these movies
i have a few dollars to put towards your
muppet movie well it's all we need just
money for felt man
that's it money for felt and the chicks
are free
um that's the last jc you got one
i'm gonna shout out uh big sky vike in
the chat
who said the muppet blues brothers and
fozzie and
ralph the dog oh that's good
i'd see that that's okay i'd buy that
how about muppet on golden pond
so that's older kermit older piggy
and uh robin
mmm hermit's nephew who's like what do
you what do you guys do
cruise chicks cruise chicks then what do
you do when you get them you suck face
uncle kermit
because you know kids mark love on
golden pond
it's their favorite movie
i was going for the most popular pop
culture reference i could
i put my finger on the pulse and i
pulled out on golden pond
i i almost went um no country for old
muppets
nice who's who plays uh
uh you know the [ __ ] dude with the
air hammer oh yeah the the javier bardem
you're anton shgurg
that's right you could be dude with the
dynamite who's always like
yeah like you're you're swedish chef or
fork
jc did you give us yours yes you did
then that's it that's it i didn't know
we ran out of show
we showed until we could show no more
we're showers not growers two hours of
show even without a guest
just yap yap yappin at all the things
you love
uh that we love too did you have a good
time tonight kids
on friday night isn't this how you
dreamed you'd spend your friday nights
looking at us talking about
falcon and the winter soldier and giving
thanks to the good folks at keeps
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash fat man
if you want to kill him your hair for
heaven's sakes
um we ain't got a show without uh the
kid who bumps in from time to time
uh give it up for jc jc one more time
where they can
buy uh tickets uh opening bit dot lee
slash scum and villainy
we'll get you there the longest bitly
address of all time
um the uh there's some slots left man
but all the prime
prime real estate's gone is that correct
yeah we got the earlier and late shows
the mid
mid like seven to 7 30 to 11 is all sold
out
nice the happy hour [ __ ]
this is school night so tuesday not for
us
that's still happening give up on that
[ __ ]
uh we ain't got no show without the guy
who's down
there there he is give it up for mr mad
mark bernardin hey
york um thanks to the good folks at
invincible for
a vibrator which i'm gonna go
use on myself i'll be honest also the
most punishing vibrator it is not a
gentle vibrate no way did you have
kidney stones
not anymore pal i'll tell you it's the i
need that kind of discipline mark
i need that kind of shouldn't be
enjoyable should be yeah
when i pulled mine out of my box um
the invincible box um i i suddenly
flashed into my head from top secret
the dude pulling the anal intruder giant
jackhammer out of a box
yeah um it is uh well
thank you to the good folks at amazon
who sent us those giant vibrators
indeed the coffee and the chocolate and
all that [ __ ] we're gonna use it and
keep watching invincible
look i was watching it without the
[ __ ] swag because that [ __ ] is
dope don't forget to watch invincible
kids
um and there it is don't forget to go
join that kevin smith club if you're not
a member
i i just uh found on the interwebs so it
must be true
april 15th is when they are allowing
indoor performances shows
things again so we could be back in two
weeks
in front of people everybody wears their
masks for the next two weeks
and numbers don't spike facts there it
is people a good reason to wear your
[ __ ] mask so that me and mark can go
back to the cantina and do a [ __ ]
show
with an audience proper people for you
for you as well
yeah we want to do a show with decent
people
not this riff raff yeah look at this
[ __ ] [ __ ] us in
cyber boxes like we're the [ __ ]
kryptonian villains and [ __ ]
no
um ladies and gentlemen
that is your fat man beyond
for this week i'm kevin smith i'm mark
bernard
you tune in next time same fat time not
the case we'll probably be on a saturday
same fat channel that never changes
facebook or spodcast.com or
youtube.com kevin smith uh
jeff's kiss everybody just kiss
you